lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre las cuentas de ahorro para
el retiro tradicionales
de ahorro
para el retiro
y en este vídeo nos vamos a enfocar en
las cuentas de ahorro para el retiro
tradicionales
ya que escucharán que hay otros tipos de
cuentas que veremos en vídeos
posteriores así que nos vamos a enfocar
aquí en las tradicionales está en
esencia es la manera que tiene el
gobierno para invitarlos a que ahorren
dinero para el retiro pero todas las
variaciones de las cuentas de ahorro
para el retiro tienen algunos detalles
en particular así que como les dije aquí
nos vamos a enfocar en las tradicionales
y aquí vamos a decir que nos encontramos
en el momento actual en el ahora y aquí
tenemos dos opciones pueden tomar
ventaja de las cuentas de ahorros para
el retiro que la abreviar cuenta de
ahorros para el retiro y la otra opción
pues es no usarlas no cuenta de ahorros
para el retiro
este tipo de cuentas de ahorros permiten
ingresar hasta cierta cantidad de dinero
del ingreso que recibamos dependiendo de
la edad y el año en el que se encuentre
esta cantidad puede variar en el año
2010 en eeuu esta cantidad es de 5 mil
dólares
dólares si es que se es menor a 50 años
para menores de 50 años y eso es para un
individuo no para una familia
será de seis mil dólares
para mayores de 50
para mayores
de 50
la idea detrás de esto es decir que
bueno si ya eres mayor de 50 años tienes
que ahorrar para tu retiro que ya pronto
va a ocurrir digamos que somos menores
de 50 años y vamos a tomar ventaja de
esta cuenta de ahorro para el retiro
ésta sea r
así que ponemos a un lado estos cinco
mil dólares
y aquí en este caso no ahorramos aquí no
ahorramos en el futuro cercano la
ventaja aquí es que estos cinco mil
dólares de nuestro ingreso no tendrán
impuestos digamos que estoy en el
tabulador del 32% tabulador de impuestos
del 32%
y de hecho permíteme escribir esto a un
lado porque esto va a aplicar para ambos
escenarios así que aquí escribo
tabulador
ya quedamos que es de impuestos del 32%
ya que tengo unos ingresos muy buenos y
esto es a la fecha el día de hoy y con
respecto a estos cinco mil dólares y
solo me refiero a esto que estoy
apartando no a todo lo demás de mi
ingreso que seguramente va a tener que
pagar impuestos el día de hoy no pagar
impuestos por estos cinco mil dólares
así que aquí va a haber
0 dólares de impuestos
los
si yo no hubiera invertido estos cinco
mil dólares en éste sea r tendría que
haber pagar impuestos de estos así que
en este caso voy a tener que pagar de
estos cinco mil voy a tener que pagar el
32% de impuestos que es igual a vamos a
sacar la calculadora así que es cinco
mil por punto 32 nos da 1600 dólares de
impuestos así que voy a tener que pagar
1.600 dólares de impuestos
hoy
y aquí estoy apartando estos cinco mil
dólares pero solo puedo hacer esto si mi
ingreso es mayor a esta cantidad si mi
ingreso fuera de ciento cincuenta mil
dólares aún con esto en el sea r tengo
que pagar impuestos por los 145 mil
dólares restantes en cambio en este caso
que no puse nada en c aire 34 mil
dólares y digamos que en ambos casos con
estos cinco mil dólares ustedes quieren
hacer algunas inversiones y ahora todo
lo que vamos a hablar se va a encontrar
ubicado en esta cuenta de ahorros no voy
a estar hablando de todo lo demás que
tengo fuera de esta cuenta aquí puedo
invertir y hacer compra de algunas
acciones pero lo que no puedo hacer es
sacar esto como efectivo si nosotros
quisiéramos sacar este dinero como
efectivo antes de los 59 y medio años de
edad no se aplicaran alguna penalización
y ahí el detalle es por eso que
todas las personas invierten todo su
dinero en su cuenta de ahorros porque no
se permite retirarlo como efectivo no lo
vamos a poder usar para comprar objetos
o cosas solo para invertirlo vamos a
escribirlo aquí porque esto es
importante se va a tener que pagar
penalización penalización
e impuestos además e impuestos
y retira el dinero de la cuenta antes de
cumplir 59 y medio años de edad hay
otras variaciones de esas cuentas de
ahorros que son un poco más flexibles
con respecto a este límite de edad
también dependiendo de la cantidad que
se ingresa en la cuenta pero continuamos
viendo la forma tradicional
esta es la limitante que se tiene en
este tipo de cuentas para el retiro es
decir yo quiero darte el incentivo de
que tomes este dinero y lo ahorres y con
esto me quiero asegurar que de verdad lo
ahorres para tu retiro y no te sientas
tentado cuando veas un auto deportivo
padrísimo o alguna otra cosa que te
llame la atención ya que de otra manera
tendrás que pagar una penalización
además de los impuestos sin embargo
siempre y cuando no saquemos el dinero
de aquí como efectivo se puede usar para
inversiones supongamos que en cuanto
pusimos este dinero en la cuenta de
ahorros para el retiro
queremos
invertir estos 5.000 en
acción
en este caso ya no tenemos cinco mil
dólares tendremos 3 mil 400 dólares ya
que tuvimos que pagar impuestos de aquí
así que en este caso lo que hacemos es
comprar 3 mil 400 dólares
en la acción
y digamos que dentro de 10 años en el
futuro en ambos casos y aquí también
pasan 10 años
imaginemos que la accionada se duplica y
en ese momento ustedes la venden
así que si deciden venderlas después de
10 años van a tener aquí en su cuenta de
ahorros 10 mil dólares después
de vender
acción la acción en este caso también se
duplicó pero sólo invertimos 3.400 así
que ahora después de 10 años y después
de vender lo vamos a tener 6 mil 800
dólares
después
bender
la acción
y digamos que ahora ustedes quieren
invertir esto en otra acción y ahora van
a querer invertir esto en la acción ve y
bueno esta es una hipótesis color rosa
ya que en esta hipótesis las acciones se
van a duplicar ahora tendremos
invertidos 10.000 estacas para abreviar
los 1000 en la acción b
y aquí ustedes podrían decir voy a
invertir seis mil ochocientos dólares en
la acción ve pero como aquí no se está
operando con una cuenta de ahorro para
el retiro se van a tener que pagar
impuestos sobre la ganancia del capital
las ganancias del capital son aquellas
ganancias generadas por la inversión de
capital y en este caso el capital se
invirtió en acciones y ya que ustedes
conservaron estas acciones por más de
diez años se van a tener que pagar
ganancias de capital a largo plazo lo
cual es menor que si tuvieran que pagar
ganancias de capital a corto plazo así
que en este caso tuvieron tres mil
cuatrocientos dólares de ganancia
tendrán que pagar el 15 por ciento de
las ganancias de capital así que esto
multiplicado por el 15 por ciento vamos
a sacar la calculadora tres mil
cuatrocientos por punto 15 va a ser
igual a 510 así que aquí tendrán que
pagar 510 dólares de impuestos así que
de estos seis mil ochocientos se quitan
impuestos y sólo les quedará para
invertir 6 mil 290 dólares y recuerden
que la razón por la que tengo que pagar
impuestos aquí es porque esto no está
operado mediante una cuenta de ahorros
para el retiro y aquí al contrario aquí
si estamos operando dentro de una cr y
aquí no tenemos que pagar impuestos y
ahora imaginemos que una vez que ustedes
invirtieron estos diez mil en la acción
me pasaron otros diez años y
afortunadamente la acción ve se duplicó
por lo que ahora esta acción vale 20 mil
dólares y ustedes la vendieron así que
tienen 20 mil dólares después de vender
action
y esto sigue permaneciendo en suceder
así que tampoco tienen que pagar
impuestos de esta ganancia en este caso
tomamos estos seis mil 290 dólares para
invertir en la acción b y nuevamente
después de 10 años vamos a tener que se
duplicó esta acción ve nos va a dar 12
mil 580 dólares al venderlo pero
nuevamente esto no está en una cuenta
sea r por lo que tenemos que pagar
nuevamente impuestos sobre las ganancias
de capital así que tenemos una ganancia
6.290 a la que se le aplica un impuesto
del 15% sacamos nuevamente a la
calculadora y esto va a ser seis mil
doscientos noventa por punto 15 15 por
ciento igual a 900 43.5 y esto lo
restamos de nuestros 12 mil 580 12 mil
580 menos 940 y 3.5 es igual a 11 mil
636 punto 5
así que después de pagar impuestos me
quedan 11 mil 636 dólares esto es lo que
me queda de mi inversión así que digamos
que ya han pasado 20 años ya tenemos una
edad mayor a los 59 años y medio y ahora
podemos retirar dinero efectivo de
nuestra seã r bueno en esta situación
esto que tenemos es efectivo no tenemos
que preocuparnos por hacer un retiro
porque es el efectivo que teníamos del
que tuvimos que pagar impuestos y ahora
que estamos retirados podemos usar esto
para nuestros gastos diarios sin embargo
en este caso donde teníamos dinero
dentro de la cr y ahora que ya
somos mayores mayores de 59 y medio años
ya que cumplimos con esta condición
podemos retirar efectivo de nuestra
cuenta sin que nos penalicen pero
tendremos que pagar impuestos así que
ahora podemos retirar no tendremos
penalizaciones pero si tenemos que pagar
impuestos y aquí la ventaja es que muy
probablemente después de esta edad
nuestro ingreso será mucho menor por lo
que nuestro tabulador de impuestos será
más pequeño digamos que ahora nuestro
tabulador tabulador de impuestos es del
25% y no del 32 como era hace 20 años ya
que aquí éramos unos dioses que
estábamos en la cima de nuestra carrera
pero ahora pues ya pasaron 20 años ya
las cosas no son como antes y nuestra
ganancia ya no es tal como para estar en
este tabulador sino hemos bajado este y
vamos a tener que pagar este 25% de
impuestos de los 20.000 que estamos
retirando y el 25% de 20.000 es igual a
cinco mil dólares aquí ya no use laca
por lo que tendremos como efectivo que
podremos usar para lo que nos plazca
quince mil dólares ahora comparemos
estos son quince mil dólares contra once
mil 636 y todo lo que hicimos fue
idéntico en ambos casos con excepción de
que aquí pusimos cinco mil dólares en
nuestra cuenta de ahorros para el retiro
y aquí no lo hicimos y aquí con lo que
ahorramos lo invertimos dentro de
nuestras edades en este caso no
ahorramos en la cuenta para el retiro de
estos cinco mil que teníamos tuvimos que
pagar impuestos y después invertirlos y
a partir de ese punto en ambos casos se
hizo lo mismo y de hecho nuestras
inversiones fueron muy buenas porque se
duplicaron en diez años y aquí se
terminó con una cantidad de dinero
bastante menor 15 mil con respecto a 11
mil 636 es casi el 30 por ciento de
diferencia en la cantidad total de
dinero que logramos y no sólo eso el
impuesto que tuvimos que pagar en este
momento fue mucho
en este caso que el que se tuvo que
estar pagando en este otro caso ya que
en este caso este tabulador de impuestos
es para cuando ya estamos retirando nos
de hecho ya casi no tenemos ingresos así
que lo importante que noten es que si
ustedes invierten en una cuenta de
ahorro para el retiro al final de 20
años en este caso tendrían 15 mil
dólares y si no lo hicieran al final de
20 años sólo tendrían 11 mil 636 aunque
claro la condición aquí es que en esta
situación del cr no se puede tocar este
dinero ni para una emergencia ni para
nada en caso de alguna urgencia ustedes
podrían retirar el dinero pero
recordemos que tendrían que pagar una
penalización además de impuestos